[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux du
sport local aujourd'hui jour de cet
enregistrement ce jeudi 14 juin nous
fêtons le retour de la coupe du monde de
football après quatre ans d'absence
pour célébrer ce jour tant attendu par
les supporters du ballon rond nous
ferons à touques entièrement consacré au
football dans les yvelines aujourd'hui
quatre spécialistes sont autour de cette
table pour donner le meilleur d'eux même
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite c'est peut-être l'un des plus
grands supporters de l'équipe de france
si la nature patriotique et n'hésite pas
à chanter la marseillaise à pleins
poumons sur devait le comparer un joueur
de football tricolore se serait sans
doute
hugo lloris le capitaine yann dujarrier
pistard dans la catégorie master son
club de vélizy 78 est avec nous bonjour
yann canda l'évoquions ce sont 110 kg
toujours aliadière
effectivement nous aimons queen léon
spécial coupe du monde aujourd'hui à
ouais mais quand même je m'attendais
abeilles s'y colle je suis sur la
prochaine fois là alors comment vous
sentez vous concédez très bien très bien
moi j'aime le sport j'aime un donc oui
la coupe du monde fait partie des
événements que je que je ne rate pas
partie de mes période de pèlerinage
non non non moi vous êtes de brad et oui
oui voilà tu en plus ou moins jeune et
que je fais tour de france juste
derrière tout va bien tout va bien on
passe à ma gauche musique c'est notre
monsieur ben rendez vous dans ce talk
c'est le tir et henri de la répartie le
michel platini
débat enflammé il est aussi populaire
que zinedine zidane dans les yvelines et
surtout attrapons des gardes du corps
doivent sans cesse je suis revue les
mouvements de foule qui le déclenche à
chaque à chaque fois qu'ils se déplacent
vous avez deviné son nom au mustapha
gharbaoui le président d'honneur de
l'étoile sportive de trappes est avec
nous bonjour j'ai été ravie je crois que
je vais partir d'ahmed en partie de
l'émission
vous avez vu le meilleur je pense que
vous pouvez zapper est passé sur autre
chose
est ce que vous êtes réellement si
populaire attrape à écouter cet acquis
valant 10 dames en l'occurrence je le
suis dans ma famille d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que c'est
l'anniversaire de ma maman
bonne anniversaire maman je suis allé la
voir tout à l'heure l'anniversaire
j'appelle toute ma famille a appelé donc
agir mais peu plus dans ma famille nous
bien sûr et attrapes
on repasse de l'autre côté à musique il
ratisse tous les ballons au milieu de
terrain c'est un mélange entre eux paul
pogba blaise matuidi et ngolo quand est
il vit football respire football qui l'a
côtoyé les plus grands joueurs de
l'hexagone la coupe du monde c'est un
peu le désert qu'il a tous les quatre
ans à georges gomis président du plaisir
sporting club est avec nous bonjour
charge
comment allez vous bonjour à tous très
content de vous retrouver même c'est
enfin je n'avais pas eu la chance d'être
avec lui mais pour un bel événement
comme aujourd'hui le début de la coupe
du monde et et revoir moustaph avec nous
très heureux je suis très heureux et je
vous savez là des ballons a le même jour
le milieu de terrain le gratteur de
ballons oui ça c'était une une partie
que j'adorais parce qu'on se met au
service des autres et se mettre au
service des autres
y a pas plus beau dans l'histoire il
postule et portera pour quelqu'un il ya
de la place avant tout comme toi on
termine à la gauche
musique c'est seulement sa deuxième
apparition dans ce
mais il va faire d'étincelles j'en suis
sûr et la taper son premier ballon à 5
ans il a créé son club de football
hassen en 2017
il sera du voyage en russie après avoir
fait le déplacement au brésil en 2014 et
en allemagne en 2006 le chef de projet
pour la ryder cup et supporters de
l'équipe de france c'est xavier
küssnacht sz est avec nous pour cent
michael brune heures bonsoir à tous et
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation suis
très heureux de discuter football de
l'arrêté de parler de golf un petit
moment pour enfin parler de ma passion
je suis très content merci mais quand
vous sentez vous en ce début de coupe du
monde est bien chez apps quatre ans
qu'on l'attend deux ans qu'on attend de
revivre avec l'équipe de france
je suis très excité je pense que comme
tout mais mes confrères aujourd'hui
alors vous êtes très excité on a
retrouvé justement sur les réseaux
sociaux une vidéo de vous devez me
questionne on la regarde et que la
commande juste après
[Musique]
certes c'est une réaction à ces vidéos
ce n'était pas prévu un bon vous êtes
réactif et très excité dans le football
c'est vraiment ma passion et je suis
vraiment très heureuse pour en discuter
avec des spécialistes
alors avant de vous présenter les
différents thèmes de cette émission je
vous propose de vous plonger dès à
présent dans l'ambiance de cette coupe
du monde les irrésistibles français le
plus gros clubs de supporters de
l'équipe de france était présent à
clairefontaine pour le dernier
entraînement ouvert au public des
footballeurs tricolores et ils ont créé
un nouveau chant de supporters un peu
particulier pour pousser les bleus
regardez cet extrait gérard depardieu
sort nous ta vodka on va la gagner chez
toi un champ dérivés un d'un champ rendu
le célèbre à marseille pendant l'europa
league
qu'est ce que vous en pensez que ce
chant bien sûr l'alcool et voilà l'abus
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé je
répète en août afin non mais justement
je pensais que c'était un prétexte pour
avait picolé parce que généralement les
grands événements ces travaux des
rastrojos on ressort toujours l'alcool
donc m parce que ça m'inspire c'est
effectivement le sport ça reste quand
même pour par définition une part
importante de notre vie et pour notre
santé avant tout donc avec modération et
avec depardieu si nécessaire mais voilà
ça m'inspire je vais ronron rendent dans
un moment la coupe du monde
on rentre dans un moment où on va tous
convergé vers la télé on va tous
quasiment communier et c'est ça qui est
intéressant à un moment donné même en
tous les cas on y mettra ce qu'on veut
près de la télé et en communion mais je
crois que c'est ça qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut retenir à un moment donné c'est on
aime on n'aime pas le football
d'ailleurs quel que soit le sport quand
on arrive sur des événements comme
ceux-là les jeux olympiques la coupe du
monde de football la ryder cup
bref des grands événements comme ça je
crois qu'il faut simplement retenir
l'essentiel c'est que on puisse se
retrouver on puisse communiquer qu'on
puisse parler de choses mais qui sont un
peu quasiment désuète pronostiquer tout
le monde a une à une théorie sur tout le
monde est sélectionneur tout le monde ce
projet tout le monde a envie tout bon et
puis ça se déroule jamais franchement
comme on l'a prévu c'est le suspense du
sport c'est la beauté du sport et je
crois que c'est ça qu'il faut garder en
tête c'est que ces voix là c'est un
événement d'abord festif heureux voire
économiques exposants penser ce champ
moi ça me fait rire ce que je disais je
me permettrai pas bien mais ça passait
pas du tout loin de là
non moi ça me fait rire et pour moi le
sport c'est aussi un endroit où on doit
pouvoir se permettre de chambre et j'ai
je trouve dommage qu'ils aient eu des
sanctions quentin
un joueur va chambrer le public adverse
je trouve que les gens n'arrivent pas à
prendre un peu de recul sur avoir de
l'humour tout simplement
enfin des gens dans un stade de foot
j'ai l'impression qu'ils la moitié de
leur cerveau quand il quand ils sont
enfin trop supporters c'est des choses
qu'on rencontre pas dans d'autres dans
d'autres sports et je trouve ça un peu
dommage moi voilà la chambre je trouve
ça très drôle le sait quelque chose que
j'utilise énormément en compétition et
pour pour détendre un peu l'atmosphère
dans les dents les entraves ddd
vélodrome mais non moi je moi ça me fait
rire et j'ai et j'ai besoin de ça justin
rapidement mais c'est pas le football
qui provoque que ça c'est le sport de
masse et il est de masse et il ya
beaucoup de monde est statistiquement ça
génère des dégénérés visionnement s'est
pas autant dans l'appartement il ya pas
tant licenciés en fonds de roulement
rugby en foot il ya ça génère donc
détention qu'en creux de la main
c'est pas le foot c'est la société dans
laquelle envie qu'il est plus en plus et
deuxièmement par rapport aux chambres
âge c'est juste que ça peut vite
dégénérer effectivement du fait de ce
que tu es donc on chambre entre nous
dans les stades simple c'est un peu par
nous et je suis désolé mais comment y
arriver il arrivait une arrivée du tour
de france sur l'aspect d'huez ce que je
désire plus de monde que j'y suis j'y
suis c'est dans la pratique du beau
monde qui génère ça ce sont les
supporters du foot qui sont un peu trop
souvent qui servent de prétexte pour la
liga ne ment en russie pas réglée
rapidement son hobby gagnent le viet-nam
tendresse de foot l'extérieur cité
d'avoir un champ qui diffère du allez
les bleus classique
moi ça me plaît beaucoup alors nous
allons maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons nous
intéresser aux supporters de football
dans le département justement mustapha
nous évoquerons également le football
féminin dans les yvelines mais avant de
développer ces thèmes nous allons parler
des retombées de la coupe du monde sur
les yvelines
la coupe du monde de football et le
deuxième événement sportif le plus
médiatique juste derrière les jeux
olympiques dans le monde 3 milliards de
personnes vous regardez cette édition
2010 8 les chiffres sont également très
bons en france quelle est la meilleure
audience de l'histoire selon vous
messieurs
dans l'hexagone la meilleure audience
meilleure audience en france on est
confiant pour une communion ou alors on
euros de grâce
l'euro 2016 non je veux dire la finale
de 98
non c'est le mythique france portugal
demi finales de la coupe du monde 2006
car unis 22,6 millions de personnes
dénonce de poursuivre et que de france
italie en 2006 arrive en deuxième
position
on en doute cette conférence italie
finale de l'euro 2000 et france brésil
en 98 avec 26 millions de personnes
mais c'est vrai et c'est pareil ça c est
ce que sont pris en compte les gens qui
sont dans un stade et qui sont car enfin
aller dix ou quinze mille à regarder le
même écran
il faut poser la question ce qui frappe
les voilà on est loin des 30 millions
personnes moustapha n'a pas pu compter
malheureux qu'on parle des amateurs de
temps en temps alors 7 millions
d'utilisations d'intel envie de faire du
football nous avons posé la question aux
événements un coup du monde qui me
motive à faire une football j'ai
pratiqué le football quand j'étais petit
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui me
donne forcément vite sur le football
mais aussi à la coupe du monde et la
nasa va faire des tonnes et voilà
bien sûr bah ouais ce jeu comme ça ça me
donne très envie de jouer au foot oui
vous avez un fail va me proposer
bah pas tellement apprécié que c'est
motivant quand vous voyez le genre en
face à hercules et tout mais je pense
patrick c'est pour moi j'envisage de
jouer avec le troisième âge sur le petit
terrain de capbreton donc oui j'ai envie
de me remettre mais ça fait trente ans
que je n'y suis plus ça donne envie ça
donne envie de le faire c'est inscrit
dans un club
celle ci
d'avoir des moments de délire juste 5 10
minutes 20 minutes mais c'est bon parce
que vous conviendrez avec moi que le
football c'est c'est des moments
inoubliables compass avec des porcs des
collègues ou des des coéquipiers si un
truc extraordinaire de l'oeuf ou georges
de mise
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce micro
trottoir les gens qui ont été
interviewés bon de pagnes ans et les
passionnés ils aiment le football et
quand il ya des événements comme abord
cette coupe du monde
je pense que ils peuvent pas y échapper
parce que football est tellement
tellement populaires et les dans les
familles et aux heures des matches après
les matches on on peut prendre un ballon
descendre faire une petite partie de
football et je pense que le fait qu' on
vit on pour l'instant ça pas démarré ça
démarre aujourd'hui
mais à partir du moment que l'équipe de
france va être dans le temps ça coupe du
monde
le pays va rentrer en jeu il va être
il va rentrer en fait tout le monde va
prendre son petit ballon va jouer avec
ses enfants va jouer que ses potes va
regarder les matchs et je pense que les
licenciés on aura des licenciés parce
que si la france va loin dans le dans le
dans la coupe du monde c'est aussi le
des équipes qui jouent bien au ballon
qui font qu'ils font plaisir qu'ils
prennent du plaisir en jouant
connu ce plaisir-là et émotion je pense
qu'il y aura beaucoup de gens qui vont
se convertir au football alors la
question sur ce thème la coupe du monde
va t elle avoir plus d'impact sur les
clubs locaux que l'euro 2016 est ce que
cette coupe du monde 2018 va-t-elle
avoir plus d'impact sur les clubs locaux
que l'euro 2016 vous votez oui ou non on
comptera volontairement ont fait un
petit duel on vous laissera apparaît
ensuite moustafa un petit duel entre
xavier et vous yann vous avez vous
commencé alors vous avez été un peu
hésitante sur neige et hésitant parce
que pour moi de toute façon les
retombées sont évidentes
à partir du moment où je parle en france
et donc dans les yvelines elles sont
évidentes
à partir du moment où la france va loin
dans la compétition donc aujourd'hui on
veut pas se prononcer le premier
mannequin juste d'avoir lieu
l'euro 2016 on ait la chance que ça se
passe à la maison avec au delà des
stades les fans zones qui étaient
présentes dans les dix villes hôtes de
l'euro et ça ça a forcément créé un
engouement qui était qui était inégale
et surtout c'était plus grands héros de
l'histoire
là la coupe du monde elle n'est pas chez
nous elle est en russie avec des matches
et un décalage horaire les premiers
commencent à midi c'est quand même je
pense qu'il faut être moins suivies d'un
côté et ensuite il y aura un impact pour
moi si la france va au moins au moins en
demi-finale ce à partir de là que le
peuple qui ne suit pas le foot s'y
intéresse yann alors moi j'ai répondu
oui parce que de toute façon dès qu'il y
a des qui les langues du monde du plus
fort qu'à l'euro enfin toujours 15 euros
oui je vais enfin après ça que c'est un
euro qui était en france mais oui il va
y avoir il va y avoir un impact on va en
parler énormément et puis mais voilà la
condition sinequanone segal le parcours
de l'équipe de france si l'équipe de
france fait le même parcours que en
afrique du sud ou au japon ça va être
très très compliqué et on va ça va
passer enfin passer à la trappe
maintenant si le parcours est beau et
c'est ce qui va se passer cette année
puisqu'on a une belle d une belle équipe
et donc normalement il n'y a pas de
raison que derrière il n'ya pas les
retombées
hier soir j'étais à la chercher mon fils
à l'entraînement et on leur a bien dit
que pour se réinscrire pour les
prochaines
il fallait le faire le plus tôt possible
parce qu' il allait y avoir un effet des
deux rives des demandes supplémentaires
dues à la due à la coupe du monde
surtout sur les jeunes car du togo alors
bien sûr comme en football oui mon fils
ne fait pas encore vélo mais met donc
voilà ray charles et petites catégories
sur les jeunes voilà il voit du football
y voit les grands qui vont avoir un des
beaux résultats
donc ils vont vouloir faire du foot à la
du foot à la rentrée et safa est ce que
vous avez été convaincu parce que vous
si vous étiez un peu hésitant sur la
question barria nous paraît xavier et en
ayant hésité parce qu'en fait
effectivement je navigue entre les ces
deux opinions que je que je valide pour
le coup mais
moi ce que je retiens c'est que en
général c'est l'aide c'est la dernière
qui a raison quoi c'est à dire que
l'euro 2016 on sait on connaît les
raisons pour laquelle il ya eu cet
engouement ça a été décrit ici
peut-être que si la finale avait été
même gagné par la france il y aurait eu
d'autres entre guillemets à un autre une
autre vision des choses mais je crois
que c'est la dernière qui prime c'est à
dire que là on parle coupe du monde
je reviens sur le micro trottoir les
gens en parlent parce que c'est encore
lointain alors ses lointains parce que
c'est en russie alors que c'était en
france si elle l'est déjà un peu moins
on sent l'effervescence
on sent l'organisation quand on habite
le pays organisateur ça se sent pas ce
que c'est c'est pour le coup ça diffuse
vraiment dans la société
là c'est un peu loin mais vous allez
voir et puis un élément majeur en
général pour des grands événements comme
ça c'est la médiatisation et on est de
plus en plus de plus en plus de plus en
plus vers la médiatisation il ya une
nouvelle chaîne de télé qui va arriver
et qui remporte les droits télé c'est
pas un hasard si c'est vraiment une
manière de dire on continue à mettre du
fric sur le foot
quitte à mettre un milliard parce qu'on
sait qu'on va aller chercher encore plus
de téléspectateurs et ces gens là c'est
pro de la com ces pros de la télévision
vont aller chercher le public et ils
vont d'eux donné les moyens pour qu'on
aime cette dernière coupe on n'est pas
dans le rétroviseur canton quand on gère
des grands événements comme ça ce qu'il
en reste c'est des audiences mais c'est
vrai que la dernière prime avant tout
donc un les pros vont s'en occuper de
l'engouement pour le foot et de
grandissant et 3 on est une équipe de
france qui est engagée
et puis et puis il faut pas oublier de
le dire il ya des gens qui sont pro
france qui aime la france et qui
supporte la france mais il ya aussi des
gens qu'on viscéralement aussi d
attachement personnel d'une culture
d'une culture comme on pourrait avoir en
france des gens qui sont en france et
qui sont bretons il ya des enfants des
portugais et qui veut se rendre à geste
après apporte une effervescence qui va
se faire autour du petit de france et
autour d'autres et qui alors je vais
vous donner sa g nous avons autant
puissant qu'est ce que chief pour la
coupe du monde
1014 si on compare le nombre de
licenciés dans les yvelines il y à une
hausse de 18% après l'euro 2016
il ya eu une hausse de seulement 7 % et
18 % en 2014 énorme 18 et c'est bien
mais sans faire concède faire un pas à
faire un guère moins d'impact notamment
après la coupure après le roc avait bien
sûr et ils sont limités mondiale le
nombre de routes du monde sait
maintenant c'est georges coupe du monde
c'est mondial s'est passé s'est passé
pas européen donc c'est tout si toutes
les cultures de tous les footballs et
les 10 les différents comment les
différents folklores parce que c'est une
fête
et puis vous avez l'allemagne qui a
gagné la coupe du monde au brésil
mais si c'était le brésil qui avait
gagné la coupe du monde je pense que les
chiffres ont été encore plus grand parce
qu'il ya des professionnels du foot
aujourd'hui comme l'italie qui sont pas
là il ya des pays émergents il ya des
pays émergents qui sont là comme le
sénégal qui peuvent aussi emmené comme
le ghana qui avait fait un bon parcours
donc là on a la chance d'avoir le brésil
avec de la qualité un football pétillant
la france qui avec un duo d'attaqué
extraordinaire on a descellé didier
deschamps qui ce qui ce qui ce se lâche
un petit peu qu'ils aient ce qui le
laisse d d d d entraînement ouvert à
clairefontaine
on les sent un peu plus ouvert par
rapport à où comment au terrain et je
pense que le un événement planétaire
bien sûr il a plus de construire enfin
d'incidence sur le nombre de licenciés
qui en est qu'un événement il est
d'autant plus qu'il ya pas l'italie il
n'y a pas la hollande ya pas je répondis
si on leur disait mousser la femme par
rapport à la médiatisation c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui en 2018 la médiatisation
est même supérieur à ce qu'on avait
avant
parce que certes les gens ont plus accès
à la télévision évidemment il ya aussi
tout ce qu'il ya autour
la télévision les réseaux sociaux les
fans de mes bien-aimés tout ce qui est
réseaux sociaux internet aujourd'hui le
ça évolue aujourd'hui les gens revoient
des images sur instagram snapshot etc
mais finalement ça ça fait partie aussi
des téléspectateurs certes en décalé
mais ça fait partie de dés des
spectateurs dont on annonce 3 milliards
de téléspectateurs pour moi avec les
podcasts et les retourner c'est même
plus et ça ira ça sera encore plus pour
la coupe du monde
en même temps la relégation n'a pas
encore commencé et je trouve qu'on en
parle déjà beaucoup plus que quatre ans
où mais maintenant je remets pour
fournir aux chiffres si j'ai bien
compris +18 europe non en france dans
les yvelines dans les médias par rapport
à la coupe d'europe nom du monde comme
armand la grande du monde bien les
coupes d'europe spéciale aussi pour
faire les statistiques on peut leur
faire dire ce qu'on veut c'est là c'est
entre guillemets c'est là c'est le
mensonge le plus et dernière élabore et
l'anr casse mais sur ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il ya promeut démocratie dam
des mots d'alain fille anna kasyan
mustapha est ce que voulait est ce que
les licenciés reste finalement après la
coupe du monde où après un euro est ce
qu'il reste non seulement il reste mais
on a de plus en plus est ce qui reste
dans le club est ce que trois quatre
mois après il n'arrête pas le foot par
exemple en effet post événement peut
être temporaire alors pour le coup c'est
l'événement il ya 3 817 salariés
licenciés dans les îles du même nom mais
l'événement permet à des gens de rentrer
dans ce sport là en particulier mais
comme dans d'autres sports quand ils
sont médiatisés à ce point mais c'est
souvent les jeunes donc les plus jeunes
voix et s'identifie et vont dire papa
maman je veux faire du foot les autres
c'est leur passion ou pas donc si c'est
leur passion ça va être amplifié c'est
une case nous c'est une caisse de
résonance de la joie qui sont excités
par le foot ils voient ça ça amplifie il
n'aime pas si ça fait un effet ils
resteront encore un peu ça va s'estomper
et s'ils n'aiment pas ils resteront pas
mais là où c'est intéressant c'est
surtout les nouveaux licenciés
donc je pense que si les statistiques on
devrait la regarder plus en plus en
avant faudra regarder par rapport à par
rapport à la démographie d'une part par
rapport aux classes d'âge quels sont
ceux qui rentrent le plus moi mon avis
c'est surtout les primeurs c'était
nouvelle équipe
nouvelle image fait un cadeau plein
d'éléments mais globalement c'est une
valse
globalement ça fait du seul fait du bien
au foot donc y reste il s'accroche où il
rentre sera loin de la fin sur cette
thématique en passe maintenant notre
rubrique focus
nous allons maintenant nous intéresser
aux supporters dans les yvelines la
proche de la coupe du monde semble avoir
réveillé les plus fervents fans de
l'équipe de france quand on a pu le voir
autour de cette table dans les magasins
la carte bleue n'a jamais aussi bien
porté son nom ce mois de juin lunettes
de soleil t-shirt claquettes les
produits dérivés aux couleurs de
l'équipe de france s'arrache dans les
boutiques évinoise le best-seller le
maillot officiel
aujourd'hui on n'a même pas besoin de
faire de publicité quoi que ce soit mes
clients quand ils arrivent la première
chose qui me demandent vous avez déjà eu
l'équipe de france oui il est là il est
pour vous donc demandé de donner peu des
merlus votre taille et puis je me ferai
un plaisir de les vouloir récupérer au
total à 6000 euros de produits équipe de
france ont été vendus en une semaine
dans ce magasin un engouement qui
devrait se propager à dans les bars dans
ce peuvent installer depuis 1998 à
voisins le bretonneux
les supporters étaient déjà présents ce
samedi 9 juin pour suivre le dernier
match amical contre les états unis
le taux de remplissage devrait encore
augmenter pour les premiers matches
officiels de la coupe du monde c'est sam
sur une soirée où il ya l'équipe de
france qui joue
moi j'ai comme j'ai dit c'est à midi on
sait pas trop mais quand c'est à 20h30
c'est
100 % de remplissage donc
l'établissement est au complet il faut
réserver pour avoir de la place quoi
pour boire un verre c'est debout et pour
manger ouais faut réserver à l'avancé
puis des places assises valent cher on
va dire alors on sent que l'engouement
monde petit à petit dans le département
les chiffres pourraient être encore
booster si la france réalise un très
beau parcours il disait tout à l'heure
sur ce plateau
quand on voit cet engouement est ce
qu'on peut se dire que les yvelines sont
une terre de football où cette ferveur
et éphémère est-ce que les yvelines sont
une terre de football au niveau des
supporters oui non on fait un petit duel
entre moustapha eliane déjà riche
mustapha pourquoi cet unitaire de
football pour parce qu'il suffit de
regarder les chiffres
moi les chichis je les connais les
statistiques et la forme la corée du
mensonge là je parle pas de ce genre de
chichi on leur fait dire ce qu'on veut
aux chiffres sont têtus et brut
je suis de regarder moi je les connais
donc son argument va vite tomber
je crois qu'on doit être une dit
district où il ya le plus de licenciés
en foot quand très mobiles en france
je parle par département cette fois ci
et la ligue de football de paris est la
première ligue de france donc première
ligue de france et les yvelines premier
département lalique ce qui nous met
globalement dans les premiers français
donc oui c'est une terre de foot
stadistes passait pas statistics ce sont
des chiffres monsieur était donc piqué
nous c'est le premier point le second
point on voit bien le micro trottoir on
voit bien l'engouement dans les stades
on voit bien dans nos dans no comment
dire merci à trappes ont le sens où le
sang voilà maintenant voilà je sais pas
trop quel est son argument revenu au
niveau du vélodrome mais vous le dire
mais mais ce que je tiens à dire et je
veux être un des gardiens du temple
quand même c'est que c'est très
économique quand même ça prend des
proportions pape s'il ya de plus en plus
de monde mais il suffit de regarder le
panier moyen dépensé par les uns et par
les autres
le nombre de personnes ne faut pas s'y
tromper les mecs qui met un milliard sur
des droits télévisés il ya du bizness à
faire donc il faut quand même que dans
nos clubs et là je remercie encore tv
fils et je remercie tous les gens autour
de cette année 78 on a changé le nom
pardon staff un pardon c'est vrai que
vous est possible vous êtes a grandi
comme ça vous êtes agrandi depuis ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il faut quand même
rester nous présidents de club tous les
clubs amateurs
ça reste un prétexte le foot pour autre
chose si jamais on partait uniquement
dans cette voie là de cette valorisation
du foot de ce sport uniquement
commercialement voire politiquement ce
serait dangereux donc oui à la fête
oui à l'engouement pour le foot oui pour
nous ramener tous ces gamins dans nos
clubs parce que ça devient un prétexte
pour faire passer aussi des messages et
des valeurs et la société n'en manque
pas après ce débat présidentiel on va
laisser la parole à yenne dujarrier
c'est à vous oui d'accord vous me parlez
de masse de la masse on se tutoie
d'habitués ensuite vous allez tu a
indiqué m
dûment de masse et de quantité de
licenciés qui est dû à la population
qu'on peut avoir en ile de france
mais moi je vais simplement parler de
qualité jeu et oui et oui je vais parler
de qualité c'est à dire que en
ile-de-france la séance publique dans
les yvelines quel est le qu'elle est là
la division dans laquelle joue le plus
au club
des yvelines et bien par rapport aux
autres départements d'île de france
je suis désolé mais on est un ton en
dessous et je trouve ça dommage
et à partir et est juste là dessus c'est
simplement un moment
l'infographie sur les clubs à ce n'est
pas la panacée
ca c on va peut-être ça sera un peu plus
tard dans l'émission le onze de départ
mais non je trouve si je trouve dommage
à voir c'est bon on a la bonne voie dans
les zéniths justement donc les meilleurs
clubs m'ont tu vois la nationale 2 est
ce moi ci fc mantois nationale voit elle
c'est versailles les murs aux régionales
deux manches entre mon char train
régional 3 fc mantois de as ou y lit
mais et en régionale 4 bien sûr on
attrape non non non donc j'ai donc je
peux pas laisser passer ça oui mais je
suis désolé mais moi je moi je vois
aussi la partie qualité mais la partie
qualité je la mets sur les instruments
s'est apprécié l'action s'ils ne font
pas le nécessaire pour qu'on puisse
avoir une équipe à un niveau qui serait
normal pour un département où il ya fait
revente qui aiment le foot les chiffres
le prouvent
et on sait également ya pas de calais on
à la fin alors c'est là où je m'inscris
totalement en faux comme on dit dans les
émissions de télé de grand public c'est
que ce tableau là je peux pas laisser
passer les meilleurs clubs mais les
meilleurs clubs c'est ce qui est du clae
monde depuis les u6 jusqu'à u19
là on parle des seniors j'ai pas mis mon
engagement sur les seniors oui j'avais
seniors c unis font gagner à des gamins
aussi j'ai mis mon engagement sur les
enfants de 8,6 à u19 pourra en faire de
futurs citoyens pour en faire des
sportifs de haut niveau l'an parle de la
une
mais la une s'est jamais qu'une
résultante
donc quand on dit les meilleurs clubs
l'e-mail les meilleurs clubs versailles
prenons les classements de u 6 à u 19 et
vous avez des clubs formateurs alors là
pour le oui mais on n'arrive pas à les
garder en bon joueur on va laisser
parler
chroniqueur moustapha il ya déjà
quelques mois pour garder pour garder je
garde un colloque formateur et donc nos
enfants sont bien formés se produise n'y
avait pas moyen
vous avez cinq secondes à l'épreuve aso
pour 5 secondes il ya deux tendances
il ya l'éducatif ayez le business on est
éducatif vous avez des questions vous
entend pas sur la question depuis tout à
l'heure mais vous et ses géantistes
applaudi j'aime beaucoup ce genre de
débat je rejoins vraiment les femmes et
pour le coup je rejoins vraiment les
deux points de vue je suis d'accord sur
le côté formation éducative de ces clubs
en revanche je rejoins yann sur le fait
que dans les yvelines par rapport au
nombre de licenciés tu le disais tout à
l'heure on en a quand même beaucoup
parce qu'on fait partie d'une ligue où
on à l'heure le plus de licenciés en
france
je suis étonné de voir quand même dès
que si peu de clubs en haut de la
hiérarchie
dix couches trop tôt alors on va parler
maintenant des autres communautés quand
même on va parler de la communauté des
communautés étrangères nous avons
rencontré la communauté portugaise
yvelinoise qui compte plus de 80 milles
à supporters dans les yvelines sur les
terrains de football et binoy depuis sa
création en 72 le club des portugais de
plaisir vibre au rythme des exploits des
lusitaniens et non de l'équipe de france
on écoute les réactions y en a certains
qui sont pour les deux moi je suis pour
les deux j'habite en france et voilà
notre famille portugaise on a dû son
portier on sera toujours toujours
derrière le portugal quoi c'est comme la
plupart des personnes qu'ils ont double
nationalité on a grandi ici
nos parents sont portugais ont fait nos
vacances au portugal donc voilà c'est le
portugal a décrit à mâcher le portugal
avant tout genre gomis est ce que vous
avez un commentaire sur ca portugais les
doigts façon avec l'immigration mais les
portugais sont crise ont ils sont
nombreux c'est parce que l'apport des
supporters mais oui mais oui si on suit
ce dossier de fervents supporters c'est
les passionnés et ils ont ils raison qu
ils ont pas attendu des réseaux sociaux
pour avoir les machos portugais donc
déjà mon époque quand j'étais jeune vous
pouvez pouvez aller voir les le
championnat du portugal dans les droïdes
dans les cafés portugais et c'est une cd
d'une portée des bonds peau des bons
commander bon footballeur c'est d'aider
des gens passionnés c'est des gens et
moi aimons le ballon le ballon rond et
moi je pense que c'est le comment les
les audiences du championnat d'europe
france portugal démontrent que ce que
vraiment c'est un pays de ballons ce
qu'on vient d'entendre je crois qu'il
faut couper court à un débat celui selon
lesquelles celui selon lesquelles parce
qu'il ya ne va y venir dont je préfère
couper court tc
selon lequel on défendre est un pays qui
serait pas la france
auquel cas où on serait pas français ou
on se répète avant tout portugais
algérien marocain le maroc qui va être
un coupe du monde il ya les tunisiens
que dans la coupe du monde vous allez
voir des drapeaux tunisiens de drapeaux
marocains
il rappelait africain drapeau allemand
les drapeaux allemands des drapeaux
anglais etc
donc faut couper court à sa lé france on
aime nous sommes français et nous
défendrons par tous les supporters
français et droit une équipe française
et on est fier de ce pays est fier d'y
appartenir fière de ses valeurs
il n'y a aucun simplement il ya une
ambiance aussi comme on est parisiens et
bretons c'est un peu là l'image que j'ai
mais on peut parler des corses de la
même façon il ya des choses qui sont
juste purement affective et sentimental
ça n'enlève rien à l'appartenance à un
drapeau et une république à ses valeurs
d'avoir un peu de sentiments aussi et
j'ai envie de dire de juste de nostalgie
donc les portugais vont supporter aussi
le temps des cigales comme d'autres pays
vont supporter d'autres télé parce que
j'ai remporté par exemple j'ai 0% les
maliennes jerry 0% ils sont c'est à dire
je suis pareil fils d'immigrés polonais
en l'occurrence est fier de la merde
apparemment du côté de malherbe ne se
soit pas trop j'ai 0% le sang français
et je ne me vois pas et pourtant j'ai de
la famille justement dans ces pays là je
ne vois pas supporter un autre pays que
la france
donc moi j'ai travaillé sur l'euro 2016
et je travaillais justement et des
collègues qui eux étaient d'origine
portugaise et il supportait le portugal
avant la france moi c'est quelque chose
qui me dérange beaucoup parce que quand
un voyant vacances ils ont peut-être
deux équipes
il est là justement ils sont portugais
pour le foot parce par contre lorsqu'ils
vont en vacances en thaïlande pour
draguer des filles sont français
non franchement franchement je le vis
beaucoup à trappes
j'imagine tout va bien nos mondes qui
ont quand même et cette relation avec
mais c'est de l'affect on n'essaie pas
de l'intérêt on est dans le foot c'est
comme si on me laissait parler jean
fabbri on est dans le football et donc
je pense que comment mon fils mon fils
ou d'autres enfants ils vont supporter
qu est-ce qui adorent naldo figo ou
parce que c'est le genre qui les fait
rêver bon et voilà donc comme comme des
commandes et des espagnols ils vont ils
vont être fous de sida lille voilà donc
dont enfants donc je pense que la coupe
du monde la coupe aph à la coupe du
monde et les supporters de la coupe du
monde c'est des gens qui s'identifient
plus à une équipe à un joueur a une
façon de jouer
c'est pas des nationalistes à les gars
c'est des gens qui aiment le moi je sais
que personnellement la roulante
c'est l'équipe moi c'était johan cruijff
je joue au foot c'était one drop et
pourtant je t'ai blacks
je ferai jamais trop lent des jo gomis
alors nous allons passer à une nouvelle
thématique aujourd'hui si on parlait
sport vous a concocté le onze des
professionnels évinois qui ont été
formés dans le 78 c'est parti on
commence par le gardien le service des
sports retenu alphonse areola dans les
buts le gardien du paris saint germain
en défense on retrouve le girondin
sabaly qui a été formé aux chaînés
mamadou sakho l'ex joueur qui vient du
chéné mamadou sakho les gens du psg
maintenant de crystal palace
aurélien collin qui jouent en mls aux
états unis à droite quoi tient le
remplaçant du fc nantes au milieu un
beau tridents avec radio mehdi lacen de
malaga et hatem benarfa et enfin en
attaque on a belfodil d'hoffenheim le
plaisir aux agents qui minent augustin
et qui est aujourd'hui en allemagne et
enfin à moussa sow qui a fini à meilleur
buteur avec lille en 2011
voilà on aurait pu être aussi le milieu
mais soupe qui joue à lens où rémi gomis
qui est aujourd'hui en suisse où fc wil
qui est né à versailles ou même killian
mba p 1 kg est passé par le centre de
clairefontaine pendant deux ans entre
2011 et 2013
on n'a pas retenu dans l'équipe il avait
d'autres choses à faire
problème de cette la question sur ce
thème cette équipe at elle sa place dans
le top 10 de la ligue 1 oui non dans le
top 10 de la ligue une problème c'est
radio tu peux faire sentinelles ça va
dans le top 10 de cette équipe
moi je dis aux comptes ou alors dit elle
serait pas imputable aussi ouais mais
non c'est une belle équipe après bon la
question elle est justement c'est bon
pour créer un débat mais c'est difficile
d'y répondre
c'est une belle une belle équipe ça
prouve que les civils sont quand même
une terre de football tard formatrice
comme je le disais moi je reviens sur ce
que je disais yann tout à l'heure est ce
que justement on n'allait pas d on
arrive à avoir des bons joueurs dans les
équipes de jeunes et que malheureusement
on n'arrive pas à les garder mais à ce
niveau là c'est encore une fois faut
bien comprendre c'est la volonté des
dirigeants et là je parle des dirigeants
de clubs mais pas simplement parce que
s'il ya des communes associées et de
financement en tant qu un moment donné
il ya un vrai savoir faire français
il ya un vrai talent chez nos éducateurs
il ya un vrai talent dans les clubs
sportifs c'est pour ça qu'il faut rester
quand même bien bien positionnée sur les
clubs amateurs et après ils vont dans
des dans des structures qui sont
formatrices avec des clubs de campbell's
à des centres de formation et et ils
sont sur des grosses équipes c'est à
dire que c'est le centre de formation
nommons m'attrape ils sont à nantes ils
sont à monaco ils sont wavre ils sont à
auxerre pascal en il ya des structures
d'accueil et de la va décoller
éventuellement bas on n'arrive pas à les
faire nous et nos politiques tonalité la
volonté des dirigeants
c'est là dans les yvelines à
clairefontaine il ya une foule et c'est
tout là il ya une couleur présent dans
l'équipe vous en pensez vous de cette
équipe
m c'est une belle équipe un bon ils
n'ont pas tous le même âge mais acdc des
talents c'est des talents et je pense
que très sincèrement cd
des joueurs qui peuvent jouer la régence
et quatinka 21 ans le plus vieux
aurélien collin trente deux 32 500
moussa sow 32 ans également entendre
deux ans donc ce véhicule à l'est je
pense que oui moi je sais si ça reste
jouable je vais aimer dans le entre 8 8
8 me dont 8 8 12e
voilà à 8/12 faire c'est un meilleur
deuxième but 12e
mais ce que ce qu'il disait dans par
rapport à la fois la foire enfin la
préformation la pré formation et
d'information c'est à dire que les clubs
amateurs ils sont amenés à 1 comment
faire identifier identifier leurs
joueurs à ces jeunes pour qu'ils parlent
dans les pôles de prévost puissions
ensuite faire de la formation et à la
fin de leur formation intégré le groupe
professionnel
donc on peut pas garder les meilleurs
les meilleurs chaque club chaque club ne
peut pas former
n'oubliez pas le psg quand même
abandonné 1 paris saint germain sa
raison des yvelines paris saint germain
boissy parler bientôt saint gilles et
saint germain donc il ya bien un moment
donné un club formateur il ya des moyens
et il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
passés par ce club
parlons d'anelka et et d'autre mais on a
radio dans l'équipe on a la volonté des
dirigeants c'est pas ce ne sont pas les
clubs
moi je suis entre guillemets focaliser
sur l'idée que d ici sur u 19
on a ce biais de formateurs et ensuite à
la limite qu'ils aillent jouer au très
haut niveau ça nous fait plaisir on
n'est pas là que pour les retenir les
mots je vais avoir joué à leur niveau et
de leur talent combien pour bien bosser
sur les jeunes proposent pour bien
bosser sur un gel et que vous les clubs
pro b pour rappel préfère l'avoir à 14
ans à 14 ans où j'ai dû le mettre dans
un centre de préformation de la
politique et de la politique technique
en france on veut on est d'aider des
pôles des polos des pôles des jeunes
dans chaque région à peu près et donc
soit il va dans un club il fait sa
préformation dans un club professionnel
soit il est dans son club
enfin il est dans le centre de
préformation
les jaunards voit la haye par la suite
il est pris pour la formation
donc si plus tard il rentre dans la
préformation ou dans la formation
plus dure sera son fondateur ho
téléspecteurs faut qu'il sache qu'on
n'est pas là produire des talents on
fait notre métier au mieux les mômes
quand ils sont bons ils sont bons mais
c'est ce sont les minorités qui sort le
reste on en fait des citoyens d'abord
aussi du second où il était en train de
compter pour que j'aille
est ce que cette équipe dernière
question sur cette équipe est ce cas là
le caractère la fibre yvelines
finalement pas ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura le caractère et line on parle
souvent d'identité dans un club
ne regardez pas à dépasser ses joueurs
et donc du coup non alors la roya colin
justement voir les photos aurélien
collin qui porte le numéro 78 oreilles
mais laisse regarder sa montre un vrai
attachement aux tâches mais quand
j'avais que certes mais c'est imprécis
moi je suis prêt en effet est ce que ces
joueurs là ont la fibre yvelinois je
n'en suis pas certain il quitte les
clubs et reviennent quand même assez
souvent il habite fonte et le fleury
notamment noyau mais je pensais aux
autres non mais je pense pas qu'ils qui
garde sept films par exemple à
l'entraînement dans les yvelines sont
attachés alors je pense à senneterre de
foudil nos énergies
des yvelines faut avouer qu'on voit pas
beaucoup de gens revenir dans nos clubs
pour signer pour peut-être alors que
alors que gillian et le label n'a fait
qu'y liberté de l'aca je crois qu'il
faut ré invention
je crois que c'est très indiquée et
thierry henry et thierry henry il a fait
aussi utilise ça fait donc créé le verso
c'est très personnel ces choses là donc
c'est vraiment les individus passait pas
c'est parlent les yvelines qui les
retiendraient la plupart ils sont quand
même ça dans les yvelines dragon soir
les yvelines
georges kaminis vous avez cinq secondes
ouais la plupart des joueurs qui sont
issus les yvelines reste dans les
yvelines en général toutes leurs parents
y habitent et jure sur tous les joueurs
vous avez cité à aller il ya 70% des
gens de leurs parents sont encore pas et
on a dépassé les 5 secondes jusqu'au
mise en ouvre maintenant notre page
débats
échauffement nous allons nous intéresser
dans notre débat au football à saint
quentin en yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération possède un club dans
chaque commune le club le mieux placé et
rap qui évolue en régionale 4
montigny-le-bretonneux maurepas et
guyancourt évolue en d1 de district et
plaisir en d2 de district un niveau
correct mais pas transcendant il faut le
dire pour une communauté d'agglomération
de plus de deux cent mille habitants
la question sur ce thème doit-on créé un
seul et unique club à saint quentin en
yvelines
oui ou non ces mousses oui à jamais
varié j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est
quand même dommage de ne pas avoir
dans les yvelines une équipe qui soit un
peu phare et qu'ils puissent justement
créé cette émulation et 7 ans l'argentin
en yvelines et bien donc saint quentin
en yvelines
avec la multitude de clubs que l'on
assure sur la quantité sur la communauté
et bien faire une équipe première qui
serait une entente est juste sur une
équipe première et qui permettrait de
voir la rayonnante et de l'art et non
sur le département et sur la région
parce que simon qu'il pourrait jouer à
un niveau qui permettrait le 2-2 de
jouer au niveau national et donc de
pouvoir rencontrer d'autres après se
dire qu'il faut un stade
est ce qu'on a le stade sur la
communauté qui permettrait d'accueillir
je pense 6 10 mille personnes
c'est pas sûr et puis et puis ensuite
bien sûr on doit plafonner à 800 mhz et
donc
donc on a en a certainement pas la
structure pour pour le faire et puis
ensuite il faut que ce soit une entente
de tous les clubs pour pouvoir aller se
dire je vais aussi voulu bien vouloir me
séparer de mes meilleurs éléments et
pour qu'ils aillent jouer donc il faut
que ce soit l'or après faut soit une
relation gagnant gagnant c'est à dire
que oui on a réussi à faire à faire de
la formation
cette équipe là va aussi nous rapporter
peut-être un peu de un peu d'argent par
la suite avec des retombées sur les
transferts les sponsorings c'est donc
voilà il ya peut-être quelque chose à
creuser
je ne sais pas si si il ya eu un essai
ou pas mais je pense quelque chose à
faire mais donne a parlé à xavier après
je vous donnerai la parole moi je crois
que mes merret
mes chefs regardé l'émission 100% quand
on y vit j'étais un petit peu obligé de
répondre rires non merci beaucoup
j'apprécie dans blague à part je
rebondis sur ce que disait yann je pense
que tout cas les ive et n'ont besoin
d'un voilà d'un fer de lance est d'avoir
un club un petit peu phare se pose la
question justement de piquer les
meilleurs éléments dans tous ses clubs
dont trappe
mais après je revenais justement sur le
fait d'avoir un stade du cou qui puisse
accueillir autant de personnes on est
dans un cercle vicieux parce que pour
avoir un stade faut avoir un club à la
hauteur mais pour avoir un club à
l'auteur folk c'est pour moi c'est une
volonté politique si on veut
une équipe saint-quentinoise moussa fall
harbaoui vous qui est le mieux placé un
sort du plateau pour répondre à la
question gars j'ai un scoop cette équipe
saint-quentinoise elle existe elle
s'appelle l'étoile sportive de train
pour un de meilleurs résultats vous
l'avez dit mais là vous ne prenez que
les seniors or je considère qu'un club
de foot je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est par les seniors qu'il faut
regarder en priorité à nos niveaux
j'entends en termes de régions mais il
faut regarder toutes nos équipes s'était
avancé mme enseignants qui rayonne le
plus on est d'accord on parler d'accord
on est d'accord si visible ok sauf que
de 6 à u 19
c'est pas simplement la première place
comprendre s'est nettement détaché des
autres puisqu'on est en rire d'eux
pratiquement partout en r2 pour ceux qui
nous regardent c'est la ligue 2 du
football pro chez les enfants et les
seniors sont aussi devant mais à un
niveau on va dire de perches de r3 ou de
ph
mais ce qu'il ya en dessous c'est à dire
no 6 en sept ans 12 ans 11 ans etc sont
nettement nettement nettement détachée
de tous les autres clubs de la ville
hélas ce ne sont pas des statistiques ce
sont des chiffres suivent et regarder et
quand je dis ça bien évidemment que
c'est une manière de parler du travail
qui a été fait par toutes nos équipes et
du club de trappes
mais c'est aussi une manière de dire que
évidemment qu'il faudrait
sauf que c'est l'arlésienne quand je
suis arrivé il ya quinze ans je les dis
on pourrait pas se mettre autour d'une
table je venais d'arriver on pourrait
pas se mettre autour d'une table
peut-être qu'on pourrait réfléchir à ça
pour quoi
pour une raison très simple c'est que
chacun pourrait garder son identité
trappe son identité ses éducateurs et on
s'occupe des enfants et on se les prend
pas comme c'était le cas une certaine
époque tourner se piquer tout le monde
est là un moment donné c'est qu'on
s'occupe de nos enfants par club paris
avec son identité etc
en revanche les seniors ils sont entre
guillemets rentrer dans le monde
professionnel en que je mets des
guillemets et là où quelqu'un pour avoir
quelque chose qui les accueillent et il
serait alimenté par les écoles de
formation des différents clubs et là ça
coûte pas cher aux contribuables d'avoir
des enfants bien formés que nos
éducateurs c 'est pas refaire ça fait
cher avec si par contre ça coûte cher
d'avoir une inquiétude au quelqu'un
plutôt que de saupoudrer sur chacun des
clubs pour avoir une équipe une donc on
mettrait tout cet argent sur une équipe
une
auquel cas en concentrerait l'argent
c'est de l'argent ils deviennent pro à
ce moment là ils prennent des primes au
minimum voire des salaires et on
laisserait nos enfants à l'abri tout ça
et on se concentrait sur l'éducation de
nos enfants jusqu'à dix neuf ans et en
aliments très une équipe saint
quentinois de meetic cinq gros seins il
y aurait une grosse pression parce que
de se dire je vais rentrer dans cette
équipe et on se les pics réparer nom
vient du fait que ces deux jeux allaient
jouer avec moi c'est la volonté des
politiques certain moment donné tu
rappes veut son équipe saint quentin
pardon voisins-le-bretonneux donc ça
c'est pas évident de se mettre autour
d'une table et je rappelle que les
associations sont loi de 1901 et donc
chaque président peut donner un avis
important
georges gomis est quand même possible
c'est possible mais pas mal à rebondir
salle est très très très très content
lille et paris 6 le soleil se dirige il
est soulagé lui permet merci à la
candidature de mustapha ben oui si on
parlait sport ces quatre là souligné le
problème quand il arrivait et le dis aux
gens ça serait bien de faire ça et le
problème de des présidents de clubs
setc il voyait pas l'intérêt général il
voyait dans l'intérêt de personne
il garde le club et le football le
football le football et c'est ce qui est
ce qui est malheureux le but le but
c'est il regarde notre travail on se dit
il travaille bien on va lui piquer ses
joueurs on est de se dire au lieu de se
dire il travaille bien qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire pour travailler maintenant
faire cette équipe là bas bien sûr ça
serait bien mais maintenant je pense pas
que tous les présidents il est là
l'intelligence et le la modestie il faut
que la modestie l'intelligence et la
modestie et la modestie de se dire mais
c'est un projet commun je mets le
mouchoir sur sur ma personne et je vois
l'intérêt général voilà donc il faut
avancer rémission continue notre
rubrique débats par du football féminin
je sais ça me tient à coeur
mustapha le club de manille à football
club a créé une section féminine pour
promouvoir au maximum cette pratique une
rencontre découverte était organisée
formé au stade de la pointe de cheveux
courts on écoute le dirigeant de la
section féminine à claude calant
derrière on a envie de de relancer le
football féminin sur manille on est
convaincu du potentiel de joueuses qui
peut y avoir sur la commune et les
communes avoisinantes cette année on se
donne le china de remonter une section
pour la saison prochaine aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'on fait c'est pas pour se
garder se dire qu'on aura trois quatre
joueuses dont on espère vraiment créer
une section féminine avec une ou deux
équipes dans différentes catégories
alors dans les yvelines le nombre de
licenciés en football féminin a doublé
en quatre ans 20 % de licenciés à
supplémentaires chaque année
il ya maintenant une cinquantaine de
clubs dans le département qui propose du
football féminin
la question sur ce thème le football
féminin at il pris son envol dans les
yvelines
oui ou non softball féminin at il pris
son envol c'est moi j'en ai mis dans les
deux offert un petit jeu c'est partager
je ne sais pas
intitulé entre vous et xavier gens je
commence alors moi je connais moins bien
les yvelines
si j'y travaille mais je parle je
pensais au football féminin en général
le rapport à l'essor que prend le fameux
féminin évidemment on le fit beaucoup
plus qu'avant évidemment que la
médiatisation permet que les jeunes
filles s'y intéressent de plus en plus
pour moi le france 98 du foot féminin ce
sera le france 2019 de l'année prochaine
et on doit compter
mais c'est pas que la médiatisation on
doit tous les clubs locaux
les comités l'agglomération les
départements faire en sorte que ce
france 2019 soit une réussite et fasse
passer un cap à so foot féminin pour moi
on n'y est pas encore
et je pense que le démarrage et les
points les prochaines là on parle de
football
evidian fin du département des yvelines
en football on parle pas de la boule au
brisas bilité et je pense que les clubs
voilà aujourd'hui le c'est surtout la
politique du district qui fait une
banque qui met des choses en oeuvre mais
il ya je sais pas moi je me cette
afrique et là les moyens qui sont mis
pour les filles je trouve que c'est le
problème le problème qui se pose c'est
qu'ils ont on a des licenciés mais pour
développer le football féminin
il faut des moyens et je pense que les
moyens qui sont mis pour les filles et
aujourd'hui on a des licenciés et le
football féminin avant ça on peut palier
parce que au nombre des équipes on est
un gros département aussi par rapport à
la symphonie no comment aux 91 l'essonne
ont créé ou au val d'oise
on est quand même un gros département
donc c'est sûr que non en terme de
licenciés on ne peut pas lier que les
yvelines cécilia une terre de comment de
football féminin maintenant quelle est
la politique ce qui va nous freiner
c'est la politique du district est ce
que le district doit donner les moyens
aux clubs de développer le football
féminin parce que tous les clubs paient
ce qu'ils veulent développer leur équipe
une on est tous d'accord c'est un
question voilà donc là les filles qu'est
ce qu'on leur donne quels parents
l'ordre et je pense que comme tu dis la
coupe du monde ça va être un vecteur
c'est sûr mais là déjà 29
voilà déjà un an déjà il faut fidéliser
fidéliser on a des ja les licenciés vous
fidélisez comment on va finir
parce qu'aujourd'hui le comment des u19
du 19
les u19 féminines vont passer leur bac
vont passer la bague après vont aller en
universités et les incidences sur les
comment sur les licenciés vont se voir
la version recevoir donc on ne peut pas
dire que là aujourd'hui on a fidélisé
donc le problème ça est de fidéliser ces
filles là parce qu'à partir à partir de
les garçons à partir de 16 ans 16 ans
ils ont le comment le brevet des
collèges
après ils ont le bac ils ont ils ont 10
ans échéance mais les filles aussi
donc les filles étant donné que
aujourd'hui dans l'eure dans la pratique
elles ont pas beaucoup de vécu
ah bon un moment ou un autre avance
arrêtés vont s'arrêter parce que ben les
moyens sont pas et voilà les moyens mais
par contre il est par la suite après la
coupe du monde
les prochains licenciés vont permettre
d'avoir une vague jusqu'à prier quand tu
les suis obligé de vous couper mustapha
la ba oui qu'est ce que vous en pensez
en veulent oui ce qui est intéressant de
savoir si quand est ce qu'on va prendre
plus d'altitude
et quel va être le paliers d'altitude
maximum mais l'envol oui mais après
c'est la volonté toujours pareil faut
pas s'y tromper
le football ça reste un business la
moitié de l'humanité joue pas au
football tu as la moitié de l'humanité
qui consomme pas sport foot
aucun amendé il faut les mettre dans la
boucle parce que ça va rapporter un
point d'accès mondiale la moitié de
l'humanité au foot ou dans le sport en
particulier parce que la promotion du
sport féminin doit être encore plus pas
que dans le foot il ya d'autres sports
sur lesquels on devrait faire des
efforts encore donc un ça reste des
consommateurs 2 l'envol oui là je prends
le club de trappes en particulier c'est
une volonté personnelle aussi mais moi
de pareilles de la même façon quand je
suis arrivé j'étais choquée qui est pas
de femmes dirigeantes dire qu'il soit
autour du club c'était purement des mecs
la volonté c'était de faire ensemble de
féminiser tout le club et qui est des
dirigeantes ça a été le cas on a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes qui nous ont
rejoints parce qu'elles ont bien senti
qu'il y avait une volonté à la
présidence ensuite les filles mais c'est
pas compliqué mille licenciés sur deux
terrains de foot on l'aimé ou tard car
on essaie juste faut être pragmatique
c'est juste les vestiaires parce qu'en
attendant
un âge aux lignes à basse et
d'infrastructures occasion petit on les
envoyait à montigny le bretonneux qui a
fait un boulot remarquable est finie et
bretonneux qui en deuxième division
jusqu'en 2014 voilà donc tant qu'on
avait lu petit on les mélanger avec les
petits et ensuite des cases étaient
grandes réserves et dans des clubs où il
y avait une structure fait mine et
montigny en particulier mais mais mon
obsession c'était à la fois de féminiser
le club donc avec des femmes et pour le
coup des femmes et des hommes à la tête
et en tant que dirigeants et
deuxièmement une équipe féminine mais je
l'aimé ou jeu il ya mille licenciés
garçons
comment je fais compliqué mais dès qu'on
a eu le stade et on la demandait pour ça
on a fait une priorité donc c'est bien
une volonté priorité aux féminines j'ai
pas d'une exclusivité une priorité aux
filles aujourd'hui on 150 filles au bout
de la troisième année on hante à notre
quatrième saison et je vous annonce
alors je ne sais pas si j'ai le droit de
le dire mais on est on a été qualifiée
pour avoir entre guillemets la médaille
d'or
cette fois-ci d'or donc on a fait bronze
argent or au niveau de la direction de
nom encadrement féminin voix qui a bien
une volonté donc là maintenant il ya une
volonté mondiale c'est de la
consommation et des consommateurs il ya
une volonté nationale et on le voit bien
dans tous les clubs où on demande à tous
les présidents de clubs de le faire y
compris magny les hameaux
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit plus de 300
400 licenciés chez eux dans leur demande
d'aller chercher des licences et de la
même façon là ce qui me gêne donc c'est
de dire il faut qu'ils aient du féminin
mais si c'est pour que ce soit des
consommatrices
alors on n'a pas fait notre boulot en
revanche si on met des filles dans le
football comme on met des filles dans le
sport en particulier et surtout dans la
gouvernance du sport en général
alors on a rempli notre mission encore
une fois
deux citoyens et citoyennes je suis
obligé de vous couper mustapha on arrive
à la fin de l'émission juste avant de se
quitter un petit pronostic sur la coupe
du monde je vais faire un tour de table
vient du jarrier qui sera vainqueur
france georges gomis moi je dirais
france pour exil en finale je peux dire
le vainqueur pas de vainqueur c'est
compliqué parce que je pense qu'ils vont
recevoir en demie j'espère bien
évidemment la france étudié tous les
tableaux à la pause j'ai l'ebit à 2004
partiel très content non j'espère
évidemment la france mais je mettrais
une petite pièce sur l'allemagne n'est
pas pareil pareil les attendre votre
peau est quand même se prononcer mon
pronostic tout le monde le connaît c'est
la france qui va gagner cette coupe du
monde mais le problème c'est que c'est
un souhait c'est un voeu mais bien sûr
la france ce serait bien toutes les
raisons qu'on a évoqué ici mais on à
l'allemagne je veux dire c'est vrai
qu'une coupe du monde c'est pour les
allemands les coupes d'europe c'est pour
les espagnols
pour les allemands mais le problème
c'est qu'on est une équipe qui est
capable de tout
on les voit il son fabuleux c'est juste
et c'est du management analyse
alors après france c'est la première
commission se retrouvent le jeudi 28
juin on va terminer par une citation du
king eric cantona sur le football
mondial des anglais ont inventé le
football les français l'ont organisé les
italiens l'ont mise en scène
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78 et surtout à bonne
coupe du monde sont eux qui sont pas
[Musique]